hi I'm Michael Moynihan with reason TV
and today we're talking to John B Taylor
off author of getting off track how
government actions and interventions
caused prolonged and worsened financial
crisis John is a professor at Stanford
University and a fellow at the Hoover
Institution John give us a rough idea of
the premise of this book and and why
this seems to go against the general of
conventional media wisdom about the
financial crisis the quiz the
conventional wisdom is a market screwed
up and need to have a lot of regulation
and rarely is the role of government
mentioned in a positive way of maybe
having caused this so what I did is
looked at the data looked at the numbers
didn't really try to look for a
particular reasonable it kept popping up
in each case that government seemed to
be there trying to do too much
frequently trying to intervene too much
and actually make things worse and
that's what I found
give us an example of a government
prevention that either created or helped
create or even prolong the crisis well I
think the easiest examples that go back
to last fall when you had this panic and
the markets crashed and you had there
you see the government coming forth with
a huge package 700 billion dollars and
you have the secretary of the Treasury
and the chairman of the Federal Reserve
going to the Banking Committee and with
only two and a half pages of legislation
kind of talking the economy down in
order to attract interest and people
were kind of shocked quite frankly and
and I think that had a lot to do with
the lack of trust as lack of confidence
and people realized government didn't
have much of a plan at that point and
tried to intervene but made it yeah what
do you make of the current situation the
bailouts the trillions of dollars that
are being thrown to god-knows-where
well ironically it's just more of the
same you know basically not instead of
looking at what has actually happened
with his government intervening
we're just doing him some more and so
this large stimulus package 787 billion
dollars doesn't do much to stimulate the
economy we tried that last year had a
big stimulus package in 2008 didn't work
doing it again you have a plan to deal
with the banks not articulated very
clearly the uncertainty again tanks the
market so it's it's really a
continuation in some sense even worse in
it I mean there is there an
inevitability about the rebounding of
the American economy and if that does
take place let's say in the next couple
of years does is it is it are we in a
difficult position as relatively
free-market people that the Obama
administration and its supporters will
take credit for for the recovery of the
American economy it's a possibility and
it's always a possibility to say this
worked and that didn't work and not
looking at the data hope people look at
the numbers because it really you can
really find out what's going on just so
just listen to somebody say something
look what actually happens it's pretty
convincing to me we have five chapters
here and and every one of them is pretty
much a question what caused the
financial crisis is chapter one 15 pages
can you give it to us in a couple of
sentences monetary excess is the Federal
Reserve took the interest rate down to
very low levels 1% kept it there for a
long time that generated the housing
boom because interest rates were so low
housing boom inevitably brings a bust
and all the foreclosures and all of the
bad debt that caused it comes from that
so monetary excesses second chapter is
another 10 to 15 pages on what prolonged
the crisis what prolonging the simplest
sort of thing is misdiagnosed it's like
a patient comes in got cancer doctor
says you got a digestive problem treats
it with something to give the
indigestion and the cancer gets worse
and in this case the misdiagnosis was
that they thought it was just a
liquidity problem not enough money in
fact it was a problem in the banks banks
had problems on their balance sheets
when you skip ahead to the fourth
chapter which is
a bit of a positive note what went right
and the two decades before the crisis I
can't imagine anything going right in
the economy at all but two decades
before things are going swimmingly
absolutely you know you think about it
was the the economists call this period
the Great Moderation or the long boom
because long expansions in really short
recessions people forget what big
recessions were but since the early 80s
all the way through actually now this is
a serious recession very smooth times
and again a lot of not a lot of
intervention kind of a hands-off policy
in many respects monetary policy filing
pretty clear guidelines a lot of
deregulation policies that freed up
markets lower tax rates all those things
which generated a consistently strong
economy for almost almost 25 years at
least two decades so now we are in the
difficulty we're in do you see a danger
that that we are going to have you know
obviously the amount of government
intervention we've had in the past past
a couple of months is frightening
re-regulation bad policy what do you see
as the idiotic solutions people very
concern with that because because again
now you know my story here isn't told
very much yeah story that government was
really at the center of this and causing
the problems that usually there's a
problem with the market so we've got
even do more yeah of these things you
know President Obama talking about the
only solution is government and so I'm
worried quite frankly that we're going
to be doing the wrong thing for a while
and it's gonna take a while to get back
on track you know it took when when
Reagan came in in the early 80s that was
it getting back on track issue because
we didn't have good performance in the
much of the 70s high inflation a lot of
instability so it's it's going to take
some effort and a lot of communication
and showing people that in fact they
nothing wrong with the market system a
lot of intervention caused these
problems thank you John for coming by
thanks for talking to us angel and
everyone should go and pick up getting
off track which is available and
calm and for reason TV I'm Michael
Moynihan